خرج محمود اللاجئ السوري الى الحياه مجددا
مع زوجته واطفاله الثلاثه بعد فتره زمنيه
قضوها تحت انقاض بيتهم الذي انهار من شده
الزلزال في مدينه اصلاحيه بغاز عنتاب
جنوبي تركيا
وحطيت راس مرتي هيك وبست راسي على الارض
ونزل السقف علينا ورجعت صارت تصير هزي
كمان يعني هزتين ثلاثه
يعني الفتره والله شقد بالضبط يعني ما
بعرف قديش اجاني صوت من بره يعني صوت
اتراك اني عم يقولوا تمام تمام يعني اني
بدي طالعونا بس عم بتهز الارض مع البيت
وسط دائره الخوف ورائحه موت منبعثه من
الجوار بات لزاما على محمود ان يمسك بخطوط
الحياه المتبقيه ويحاول
النجاه صرت اضرب يمين ويسار مد ايدي يعني
بدي انقص حالي
وصرت تهزا واخذه وجيبها وهيك اخذه وجيبها
وتفشتها نزلت وين بالارض وين نزلت والله
ما بعرف وفتح الطريق شوي طريق فتح لكنه
غير كاف للخروج من قعر الركام الذي كاد ان
يتحول لقبر لولا اراده الحياه وانا ومنبطح
يعني لا يعني ما في عشره سنتي فوق راسي
يعني حيط سقف
وعم بسحف وبطلع صرت افتح طريق وشيل بلوك
وما بعرف ايش اغراض وكركبه وقزاز وشيل عزل
طريق هون طبعا كلياته انا عم بسحب على
بطني يعني
طلعت هيك شفت اجاني مثل اجاني هواء يعني
شميت هوا شميت مثل اذا شفت السماء مثل
الحلم ضو ما بعرف يعني ما بتذكر بالضبط
ايش بس قلت لمرتي ان شاء الله فرجت ان شاء
الله بدنا نطلع وصرت عزل الحجر وبلوك وشيل
قدامي وامشي
اطلعت هيك لقيت الشباك لقيت الشباك مكسور
كله مطعوج اذا نافذه وحيده للحياه ستنقل
هذه العائله من ضفه الموت الى ضفه اخرى
وشفت السيخ سيخ الشباك مطعوج كماجته طلعت
الحمد لله رب العالمين طلع مكسور من طرف
واحد
صوره الويو بايدي طبعا انا متشطح يعني
بس ينكسر معي ما انكسر بس الا والحمد لله
وطلعت فاتحه يعني هيك فاتحه هيك يعني
الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني شيء خلصت حالي
انا والاولاد
الحياه اعطت هذه العائله فرصه جديده
لكنها لم تعطي عوائل اخرى تلك الفرصه
الموت تلقفهم تحت اطنان من الركام والالم
وصرخات الانين زيدان زنجلو العربيه من
مدينه اصلاحيه غازي عنتاب